bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
fait fort avec mon sur arte france
quel est votre constat le constat c'est
comme vous l'avez dit d'un ak d'une
aggravation des troubles psychiques chez
toute la population avec certaines
populations cibles les jeunes les jeunes
étudiants qui voient pas vraiment leur
vie d'adulte suspendu à ce cette période
pleine d'incertitudes et puis les
commerçants qui voient leur activité
professionnelle et donc leur vie la vie
de leur famille par pareillement
suspendu aux décisions gouvernementales
donc on a véritablement une aggravation
des troubles anxieux en termes dépressif
et en terme de passage à la conduite
additifs prise d'alcool de patients et
conduites suicidaires et vous pensez
qu'on est là face à une bombe à
retardement
on est là face à une bombe à retardement
c'est un conte avait utilisé des
premiers confinement en disant que ça
risquait d'avoir un impact extrêmement
lourd dans le temps pour les générations
de tout âge avec en particulier les
jeunes générations
on a souvent tendance à s'imaginer que
les trous ont lieu tout de suite mais la
particularité d'être ou traumatiques et
la suprématie
on est confronté un événement il ya la
mort qui rôde y l angoisse de la mort il
ya tous les bouleversements ce deuil
avec ses perspectives par rapport aux
rythmes habituels excès on sait que les
troubles ne vont pas forcément être
immédiat certaines fois des semaines des
mois des amis plus tard et à l'exemple
qui a été donné par votre mandat vise
peut se passer après la seconde guerre
mondiale on a eu des personnes qui ont
des troubles des derniers après la fin
de la guerre donc c'est pas un risque
particulièrement important pour les
générations en particulier les plus
jeunes c'est vrai que cette crise
sanitaire malheureusement elle perdure
elle a débuté au début de cette année
anxiété dépression des primes
finalement ça augmente au fil des
semaines au fil des mois
roanne
différence importante entre premier
confinement il deuxième le premier on
avait une date butoir d'août les gens
s'étaient mis en tête d'organiser
c'était loin ses visions et pouvant ça a
été particulièrement violent pour
certaines familles et sert par enfant
l'a vu avec l'augmentation des problèmes
de maltraitance
il y avait une période limitée là c'est
extrêmement compliqué ce isolé patients
et qu'ils n'en voient pas d'issue ils
n'en voient pas le bout et au niveau des
consultations autant lors du premier
confinement avaient nos passions à vis
de peine mais autant là avec la deuxième
phase de confinement on a des personnes
et on voit sont les appels sur les
plateformes téléphoniques et des gens
monsieur madame tout ans qu'il n'avait
jamais eu aucun trouble psychologique
précédemment mais qui sont épuisés
psychiquement parce que le stress à vous
épuise l'incertitude ça vous épuisez en
voit pas l'issue
on n'arrive pas à se voir quand est-ce
que ça va se terminer et l'être humain a
besoin d'eux un minimum de certitudes et
vend raconté que par sécurité bas ils
développent plus facilement d'être la
france qui fait partie des plus gros
consommateurs d'antidépresseurs
ça veut dire que ce n'est pas prêt de
s'arrêter ça va pas changer
alors ça pourrait évoluer si la france
se donner les moyens de former des
psychothérapeutes de rembourser les
psychothérapies d'avoir des
psychothérapeutes accessible pour tous
le traitement médicamenteux une idée
bien évidemment mais il n'est pas
suffisant et malheureusement on en moins
les limites on a besoin en france
d'avoir des moyens en professionnels
formés et à ce niveau là il ya un manque
criant qui est patent dans tous les
départements
ce soit un petit peu long comme
psychothérapeute ont 6 4 vous avez les
moyens vous avez des besoins
professionnels par moyens vous avez des
psychologues ou des epci qui n'ont pas
la même expérience dans ce domaine là
donc un véritable problème il faudrait
que ce soit accessible pour tous il
facilement c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
à moi avoir un hand attendant certains
sont en fait des copies au pédagogique
aux logiques moment là dans certains
régions est et les jeunes est ce qui
vous inquiète particulièrement
et je nous inquiète particulièrement en
tout cas la la la
deux catégories des bébés et tout-petits
parce qu'ils vont grandir avec une
banalité interactive très particulière
parce qu'ils vont grandir sans pouvoir
s'ajuster au visage à cause des masques
et on sait pas du tout les conséquences
que sarah ça n'est jamais arrivé dans
l'histoire de notre population donc on
va le voir probablement dans le temps
est ce que ça fera des enfants plus donc
sur injonction ne sais pas ça reste une
incertitude et les jeunes adultes les
jeunes étudiants qui voient alors vie
étudiant complètement mise en suspens il
y en a beaucoup comptent a pu valider
leur master 2 c'est à leur dernière
année d'études pas rire lorsque je
m'inquiète pas valider leur année
d'études parce qu'à patinage possible à
cause des contraintes sanitaires
donc si une vie suspendue et où l'avenir
ce qu'on leur propose c'est quoi c'est
la terre crie bio qui brûle c'est des
problèmes théologiques c'est le chômage
c'est des séparations face et des choses
et je prie avant de rentrer nous avons
besoin des adultes pour avoir un message
d'espoir et au delà du vaccin un des
messages histoire qu'on peut donner
c'est que le virus espagne quand même de
mieux en mieux
ils ont besoin la bulle qui tiennent le
choc parce qu'ils sont seuls et seule
phase débute à sécuriser l'enfant et
jeunes adolescents et jeunes adultes et
particulièrement à sécu les autorités
disent prendre ce problème au sérieux
ce que c'est le cas selon vous quelles
sont vos attentes dans les discours il
ya toujours beaucoup de bonnes
intentions et dans la pratique dans la
réalité il ya eu des recrutements aux
gens qui sont pas spécialement formés
pas forcément expérimenté ceux qui le
sont sont complètement à bout de souffle
parce que totalement épuisé donc il ya
un véritable besoin de formation
professionnelle sur la question du
psycho 1 et de moyens donnés à la
psychiatrie qui soient des moyens réels
et pas des moyens de campagne et de
l'enfumage communicationnel positives
comme on en voit trop souvent on a un
réel besoin de personnel réel besoin de
personnes formées eux qu'il s'agit pas
avoir de la bonne volonté pour prendre
en charge des gens qui souffrent on a vu
lors du premier continent où j'étais
souvent et pas mal d'autres personnes
qui faisait des écoutes avec beaucoup de
bienveillance du coup tant qu aucune
disponibilité mais entend des gens
pleurer toute la journée entend des gens
suicidaire opérer des crises suicidaires
d'avoir intervenir en en charge ça
nécessite d'être formé on ne met pas au
bloc opératoire des gens plein de
volonté pour vous opérez est bien aussi
on va avoir la même attention portée aux
victimes et en france ça n'est pas du
tout le cas
si je peux me permettre pour fermer mais
un conseil que vous donneriez pour aider
justement à traverser cette période
compliquée car de conseil le premier
restez pas seul essayez-le mètres autour
de vous et moyens de communication de
relais avec des proches quels que soient
les moyens par téléphone par skype
n'était pas seul ou en tout cas s'évader
dans sa tête c'est aussi important et en
évitant de prendre des consommations et
les produits qui sont de l'évitement et
qui peuvent vraiment conduire après des
foules importantes qui deuxième conseil
c'est se projeter sur des choses
positives on est toujours sorti
l'humanité toujours sorti par deux
crises d'asthme en crise intense
mystoires nous permettent pas repensé
donc c'est aussi important de se
raccrocher à ça on va en sortir ça va
pas être simple mais ensemble on s'en
sortira de façon beaucoup plus forte que
tout ça merci beaucoup pour tout ces
conseils hélène hains romano
psychothérapeute spécialisée dans le
psycho traumatisme